right we are on the home stretch so here
comes question three
the point p has position vector o p and
then it gives you all the numbers point
q and its position vector point r and
its position vector relative to an
origin o
and then they say there's some point s
that makes p q r s
a parallelogram
find the position vector of that point s
so let's think about this for a second
you've got p q and r and they're locked
in place and then as you move s around
you can put s in a particular place that
makes pqrs a parallelogram so what is
the s that will do that now we've
already said this once before for a
mechanic's question but here i'm going
to say it again because different
context even though this the point is
the same
the areas that crept in for this
question almost all of them would have
been easily solved by a basic diagram
and you're going to see how basic my
diagram is in a second but people didn't
draw a basic diagram and it would have
taken them all of like 15 seconds
but their lack of that diagram just sent
them completely down a rabbit hole or
left them
kind of
easily able to you know make mistakes
because of all of the arithmetic errors
that sort of creep in and the lack of a
diagram you know short circuits your
ability to work out that you did
something wrong okay so let's have a
look at how i would set out a very
simple diagram for this this is question
three
and we're on part a so we're told that
there is a parallelogram of some sort so
i'm going to draw myself a parallelogram
i'm going to draw it something like this
that'll do okay
i know i'm cheating that i can draw
perfect parallelograms on this app but
you don't need a perfect parallelogram
to do what i'm about to do which is the
important part i'll leave it down there
so i'm told that it's a pqrs
parallelogram so i'm going to put p here
q here
r over here in the top right hand corner
and then s right
and p q and r the coordinates are
provided to me right so i know that p
is at three comma two comma three
q is at negative four comma one comma 4
and r is equal to 3 comma 4 comma
negative 3.
all right now s is the unknown right i
don't know where it is so i'm going to
call it x comma y
comma z now what i'm going to do here is
i'm going to show you um yeah i think it
probably would be plausible for me to
show you a couple of ways to do this um
but i'm going to start off first by
what's the most straightforward way i
think
so as i mentioned right you've got this
parallelogram here and you want to say
well where is s going to be and you want
to use the properties of a parallelogram
okay so the easiest thing for instance
is to make a comparison between say
two opposite sides like this one here
and this one here these two sides of a
parallelogram are since they're a
parallel parallelogram they're parallel
not only are they parallel they're equal
in length right so in magnitude speak we
would say they share the same direction
and magnitude which means that they are
the same vector essentially right
so therefore i can say that
this vector here starting from s going
to p is the same as the vector starting
from here r going to q and this is the
first problem that crept in
some people said yeah i'll compare these
two sides or you can compare the other
two sides it doesn't matter but what
happened was you got your direction
mixed up right so you might have said
i'll say this in alphabetical order so
i'll go ps uh in the first instance and
then i'm going to go r q in the second
instance because i don't know you were
confused now in this case you can see by
my vectors while the magnitude is still
the same the length of these vectors is
identical the direction doesn't match
anymore they're going in opposite
directions right so therefore if you
equated these you would have got the
wrong x y and z because you're comparing
the wrong two vectors right
other students still they compared the
wrong two sides they might have compared
like this one and this one which were
adjacent not parallel not opposite to
each other and there were even some
students who compared like sq
to
um
pr which they're just they're diagonals
like what are you gonna do with that i
suppose you could do a dot product but
boy is that excessive because you define
that length it was just pointless okay
so like i said this would have been
easily solved for your the problem would
have been easily avoided if you just
drew a diagram like so so this is the
way that i thought was the most natural
to solve it if indeed um s p
equals q
r um i can work out what s p and um uh
sorry not q are it's
rq r q that's what i just showed on that
diagram over there even d vs are the
same then i can just do this in column
vectors and do all the comparisons right
so if you have a look here right
you can see x is going to match with 3 y
is going to match with 2 z is going to
match with 3. so that s p vector is
going to be i could state it as
x take away 3
y take away 2 and z take away 3 again
and i'll do the same thing for rq right
just be mindful for your negatives here
so you could go say for example 3 take
away negative 4
is going to be plus 4.
and then i'm just looking across there
it's going to be 4 take away 1 and then
it's going to be negative 3 take away 4.
and you can see here i can just number
one simplify all of these they're very
the arithmetic is very simple and then i
can equate the x's equate the y's equate
the z's
and i'm done right so i'm going to say
equating
components
and i'm just going to do them one at a
time
x minus 3 is equal to 7 so therefore x
equals
10. that's it wasn't hard
y minus two is going to be three so
their y is going to be five and then
lastly uh z take away three is going to
be
negative three that's the negative
what am i doing minus seven so i'm gonna
add
3 both sides which gives me negative 4.
so therefore
uh what's the point s
is at
let's see here 10 was my x 5 was my y
and negative 4 was my z
finished uh they in fact should have
been some of the easiest three marks in
the entire paper um so you needed to
make sure you didn't get the order wrong
and make sure you knew what you were
doing with your with your diagram okay
now i will show you as promised another
way to solve this and i'm also going to
show you why i didn't like it it's
clever in a sense but it's also i mean
so many of the students who did this
made errors in very obvious areas and
you'll see why in a second once i unpack
the method why the errors emerged
people said things like uh you know
what was a classic one i think someone
said something like s r is equal to p
q is that another way of saying it s r
yeah here we go so here's s r and that
is indeed equal to p q so you start off
it's all fine okay now from this point
here people then kind of went vector
crazy a little bit right so they said oh
the way to say s r or if i do that in
vector notation is o r take away o
s and uh the same thing for the right
hand side is o q
take away o
p so that's all fine i can then um add
os to both sides and then subtract
everything on the right hand side from
both sides so i get os
equals let's think about this so i'm
going to get
r take away o
q
plus o
p okay that's what you get and this
result i should clarify is exactly right
let me prove it to you if i took this uh
diagram over here
okay let's just lay it here
okay so if i say there's some o
some origin somewhere right so let's
place it say use another color let's put
the origin say somewhere like
here okay
what is our minus oq plus op think about
what this is going to be equal to okay
so if i do o r o r starts from o and
goes all the way up to here
so there is o r
uh what is minus o q well if you think
about this carefully oq
is going to look like let's use another
color here so i'll make it a little bit
thicker so it's easier to see oq is
going to go up this way okay but
minus oq is going the opposite direction
so if i take this
and duplicate it over here you can see
oq heads upwards but minus oq heads
downwards so there's minus o q
and then i'm going to do plus op so
where's op op is going to be here in
this corner from the origin all the way
over to p
like so
and i'm doing it in the same direction
so there's op so if i now duplicate this
there's op again ta-da you can see lo
and behold it lands you on s
there it is there's o p so you can see
we'll p it's a bit of a weird way to go
about it starting from my origin right
there if you do o r minus o q plus o p
sure enough you get to s and you should
have the right answer
here's the problem when you were doing
this when you're doing this working and
almost everyone who tried any approach
in vaguely like this fell into this trap
sometimes you fell into this trap more
than once and it was really upsetting to
read
you're going to have a series of oopsy
daisy a series of negatives and double
negatives in here when you do when you
evaluate this line okay you can have
negatives and double negatives you've
got to keep track of all of them you're
trying to compare the x's and then the
y's and then the z's and almost every
time you just were plagued by arithmetic
errors that are very very hard to spot
so you know when we talk about like
there's multiple ways to solve a
question right sometimes we say what's
just the fastest way right what has the
least lines of working
um other times like here what we want is
not necessarily the fastest way like if
you have a look at these lines of
working they're quite long as compared
to this some people might say this is
much more succinct right but this
particular form it just leans you into
making human errors and you are doing
this as a human being so this method
that i i showed above is much less error
prone than this one
the number if you go through your paper
and you count the number of double
negatives that you made a mistake on um
you'll probably cry a little bit because
they're simple things like we know it
doesn't mean you don't understand how
negative numbers work what we also
equally clearly know is that your
working memory was overloaded
concentrating on harder parts like 3d
vectors or integration by parts or
whatever it happens to be and then you
tripped up on the simple stuff so i
always like to say it's the cognitive
equivalent of forgetting to pack your
toothbrush when you go on an overseas
trip um on an you know to another
country or even to somewhere just a
little further afield you know you
needed your toothbrush of course you
needed it why did you forget the answer
is you were concentrating on your
passport and your money and your flight
and all the rest of it right so your
working memory was overloaded and you
forgot something simple so please make
note of that lesson it never goes away
they're not silly or careless errors
they are things that we can actually
avoid if we choose our methods more
carefully